We now have new allegations against beleaguered
Republican Congressman Matt Gates. We've already
discussed his alleged involvement in child sex
trafficking and or possibly paying minors for sex.
There is a whole world of scandal for Matt Gates
related to that. But now there's a totally new
problem for him. He is suspected of being
involved in a shill candidate scheme. Now,
a shill candidate scheme or a ghost candidate
scheme is one where if I'm running or if my
friend is running, I might induce or help someone
else run, not because I want them to win, but
because I want them to siphon off votes from my
opponent. And I'll explain exactly how it worked
in this case. In Florida's thirty seventh and
thirty ninth districts, Alex Rodriguez and Celso
Alfonso ran for office. One of the candidates has
already been charged. The believed mastermind is a
guy called Frank R. Tilles, a resigned Florida
senator. And now we've learned of a third Schill
candidate named Justin Ayanami, who ran in the 9th
District in Florida. All three of these candidates
appear to be funded by the same dark money through
a PAC called our Florida PAC and a PAC called
The Truth PAC for Central Florida. Both PACs are
funded by a single, untraceable Atlanta company
called Proclivity that made only one expenditure
to a printing company called Advance Impression.
It's all weird. And the Matt Gates piece is that
Gates appears to be connected to that central
Florida aspect of this. And the idea is that
Justin Jannati ran as an independent to help the
Republican Jason Obrador win by taking votes away
as a left leaning independent from the Democratic
candidate, Patricia Sigmon. Every aspect of this
is imploding. Florida lobbyist Chris Dorward,
who is the person that talked to Matt Gates
about the Schill candidate, Justin Einaudi,
resigned on Friday from his lobbying
firm. Now, it's important to understand
it doesn't appear that the being involved
with creating a shill candidate is illegal.
The criminal part and we're still learning
this is my best reading as of right now. The
criminal part would be the dark money funding all
of this. And it's basically just a spoiler scheme
that appears to be legal as long as it's funded
legally and transparently. And the idea is,
if I'm a Republican and I'm running against the
Democrat and it's expected to be tight 50/50,
it could come down to a half point. I go out
and recruit a left leaning independent to run
so that they will siphon votes away from my
opponent and I as the Republican win. That's
the strategy. In a sense. This is what Trump was
doing with the reports that people around Trump
were advising and encouraging Kanye West to run.
The belief being if Kanye runs, it'll take votes
away from Joe Biden and it'll be good for Donald
Trump. It's a slimy practice. It's not a new one.
It appears to be legal as long as you do it in the
particular way where the funding is transparent.
Democrats could do this. Democrats could do this
by starting to register and help libertarian
candidates run across the country. You might
have a tight Senate race, could be 51 49 for the
Republican. You bring in some freedom, free market
libertarian, and then if they take three points
from your opponent, you win. That's the idea. Will
Matt Gates ultimately get arrested for something
or is he going to escape scot free for everything
he is suspected of? Let me know your thoughts.